just transing
just transing the kids transing
the economy we're transiting everything
the democrat premise here
is
what you say
will entirely determine reality
and this is why the all the transgender
stuff actually matters here
the premise is
if you say that a recession is not a
recession
then it's not a recession
the power the power of our speech is
such that we can totally change reality
if you say that a baby is not a baby
it's not a baby
when we all talk about the royal baby
you know prince william and his wife his
wife is pregnant they're about to have
the royal baby we all talk about the
royal baby we don't talk about the royal
fetus or the royal embryo or the royal
zygote or whatever because that baby is
wanted and so we talk about him honestly
like he's a baby but when we talk about
some woman who maybe doesn't want a baby
we say oh it's not a baby it's not a
baby unless you want it whatever we say
that's what determines it
you you had a little boy but maybe some
perverted parent wanted a little girl
actually
and so they pushed the child into the
transgender ideology
well okay you can have a little girl
just call him a little girl put him in a
dress he's a little girl
that's easy
no we don't we don't need to worry about
reality we can just change it with our
language and that's what parents are
doing there's a tick tock that just went
viral i think i've got a block tick tock
on my except that it's so funny in a
really dark sad way tick tock is very
funny there are some parents who just
went viral because they held a gender
reveal party not a gender reveal party
for their baby a gender reveal party for
their toddler because the toddler
apparently is transgender
what are you waiting
we practice acceptance is what they
write and they say it's a gender reveal
and they've got the little transgender
flag and then
the the poor little kid is excited
because because the parents are throwing
all sorts of fun little glitter and
things in the air and so the kid is
excited not realizing the these parents
are
sexually abusing the child
why are the parents doing this i don't
know because they're sickos maybe it's
satire maybe i don't know that it's
satire the line between satire and
reality is pretty blurred these days i
don't think it's satire
it'd be kind of weird to subject your
kid to this in public
if it were just a big joke or you were
making just some political point about
how transgenderism's crazy so i think
they're doing it for real and they're
doing it for clout that's one of the
reasons that parents are pushed to to
trans their kids is because that's the
new hip cool thing to do and that makes
you really cutting edge and avant-garde
and liberal and socially acceptable so
that's one of the
uh social
uh
impetuses for for doing this uh they are
getting clout they are going to get lots
of likes and they are going to go viral
and it's going to give that mother all
of the attention she's always craved and
so that will happen
but why is the culture
giving the parents this clout it doesn't
just end with the culture okay i know
we're so fond of saying politics is
downstream of culture and we've said it
on the right for 10 or 15 years but
there's more to the story than that
culture is also downstream of politics
so one of the reasons why this is being
encouraged and promoted is because we
now have laws in place that encourage
people to trans their kids
we have laws and regulations in place
where if you don't trans your kids you
can be in trouble you can be accused of
child abuse or neglect we have laws and
rules in place where teachers and other
other ministers of the state can trans
your kid without your knowledge we now
have laws in place
going all the way up to the civil rights
act that have legal protections for
gender identity there are enshrining in
law this idea of transgenderism
so the law the politics not just the
culture but the politics and the
government and the law are creating
incentives for transgenderism and are
punishing people for upholding the
traditional and correct view of sex and
gender and so that's that's something
else that is pushing the culture
in this direction
i'm glad you like that clip we are so
close to 1 million subscribers here on
youtube ring the bell get the
notifications we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you